some secrets
[Music]
are too dark to uncover down man it's
[ __ ] intro welcome to yandere
simulator today we're gonna uncover some
secret some Easter eggs if you will in
this game now I uncovered these secrets
all by myself
didn't look up any tutorials didn't read
any tweets this is just pure pure gaming
extra skill why do I have so much better
in my mouth okay so what we need to do
step one go to the old clubs thing ah
yes now as you can see there's a ritual
knife in this skull it is in our hands
now step two kills someone
[Music]
okay so here we are what up [ __ ] bad
things happen to good people I need a
knife back my Janus will rule the world
oh [ __ ]
that guy's seen some great ass isn't
that right
if only simply would appreciate dahlias
dahlias dahlias dad is dad is that you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now that is jaw drop then I can
appreciate what is that my fellow my
brother why does this guy sound so
sexual all right let's talk to this
thing oh [ __ ] yes please what come on
how about that [ __ ] ayyy
that's boob physics I can appreciate
boob physics that seem like they're made
out of jelly in space
[Music]
perhaps you want to become one of us I
mean yes the [ __ ] are you wearing anyway
we got pyramids on your nipples well I
got mountains as nipples [ __ ] curse we
gotta prove that we're worthy right oh
yeah I'll prove them I'll prove to
everyone except I will notice me and
we're gonna make out after after lunch
this school of backyard oh god she's
switching she's losing it we're losing
her doctor oh well uh what what is this
no oh god what is this I never seen this
before no oh we got to redo everything
oh that's great no I'm happy about that
[ __ ] [ __ ] out duck in the [ __ ] ass
fine then I killed everyone [ __ ] you
it's a lot of work being a young Gary a
lot of [ __ ] work people don't
appreciate people don't appreciate what
I do for your son fine all right so now
we're gonna cut you all up into little
bitty pieces all right now do I get the
power I've been super duper good all
right I mean we've been over this yes
Jarett what did I do wrong Jared
look at this mess Jared just put you
back on the torso Jared let me take a
picture they have this thing called now
like the delinquents which is like the
Yakuza clan of people and probably they
like to sit squatted we got the the
[ __ ] glam hey don't tell me how to
scram get away
[ __ ] you get away I've you not [ __ ] all
of y'all
[Music]
Oh what's up with me how about what's up
with you
[ __ ] I got a crush on this [ __ ]
[ __ ] get out of here senpai what are
you to senpai calm down
Steph I oh my gosh she's acting strange
oh I'm acting strange
how about you all right what am i doing
that's so weird
that girl is kind of weird calling me
weird you're the [ __ ] weirdo she's
starting to freak me out
starting to freak me out what hey cut it
out that's really creepy leave me alone
what never face my senpai again [ __ ] you
know that's all the bad at the time we
have for today thank you for watching
gender simulator I love this game and I
really appreciate the support that I get
from you bros there are a few more
things we could check out so maybe I'll
do another one pretty soon and if you
want leave a like I'll see you bro oh my
god [ __ ] christ huh